- Alors que l'Espagne
et le Brésil déplorent leur
premier mort lié à la variole
simienne, la ville de New York
déclare l'état d'urgence
iriririre pour ralentir
la propagation du virus.
Là-bas, plus de 1200 personnes
ont été infectées.
Et des associations réclament
plus de vaccins.
des vaccins. Tout cela aurait dû
être fait hier", précise
ce militant.
Si bien que les États-Unis
demeurent le pays qui enregistre
le p c c c cas dans le monde.
La situation préoccupe aussi
les scientifiques à Montréal,
à un jour des festivités
de la Fierté.
Dr RÉJEAN THOMAS, fondateur et
prés.-DG, clinique méd. l'Actuel
- D'abord, il n'y a pas assez
de gens qui sont vaccinés,
à Montréal : 13 000, on visait
25 000. Ça, ça aurait été
le minimum. On a dit aussi
au début qtatatatait une maladie
bénigne, peut-être que ça a
diminué un peu l'anxiété,
mais on voit quand même
des cas sévères.
- Même si certains membres
de la communauté LGBTQ hésitent
encore à aller chercher
leur première dose de vaccin
coa a a a variole simienne.
- Parce que nous, on est
un couple fermé, exclusif,
donc... à priori, on s'attend
pas à l'attraper.
- C'est pourquoi le personnel
du CIUSSS Centre-Sud à Montréal
tente de sensibiliser
les personnes à risque
de contracter la maladie.
PETER FORBES, médecin retraité,
CIUSSS du Centre-Sud
- Si vous commencez maintenant,
puis quememememe donnez vos
cartes d'assurance maladie, ça
va prendre à peu près une heure.
On est tellement habitués
avec la COVID, maintenant,
où on se dit : On ne pourra pas
atteindre tout le monde,
ça prend trois, quatre doses.
etc. Bien, c'est pas la même
chose avec la variole.
C'est vraimenenenene dose
va faire toute la différence.
- À cette clinique
de vaccination éphémère
sur la rue Sainte-Catherine,
on espère ainsi inoculer une
cente e e e personnes par jour.
- On va faire ça sur ton bras
ici?
- Pour certains, cpepepepetit
geste compte.
- Je pense que c'est la bonne
chose à faire. "Pride's"
la semaine prochaine, fait
qu'il faut qu'on se protège.
Ici Gabrielululululx,
Radio-Canada, Montréa